こんにちははじめ社長です
ここはオウムの自分所なんですけどもユーチューバーの事務所というと
たよ5 a 張ってばっかり人が多いんです
午前とか60歳を超えてくるといなくて
なのでこのユーチューバーの事務所運営いるとおじいちゃん世代の方がいないので
きっといるとびっくりすると思うん
なんでびっくりするんでもし今回ルームの済みそのど真ん中におじいちゃんの2で言っ
たらどんな反応するのか
ちょっと検証していきたいと思います今日はよろしくお願いますよろしくお願いします
何をするかと言いますと今からちょっと do 目で働いている方がどんどん来ると
思うんですけども挨拶をしていただきたいと思っています
挨拶がブンブンハローいう中
文化論輸入ハローいう中ばっちりでございます3人でやってみます
のブームんハローゆる2完璧で今効果
ブンブンハロー youtube
ブンブンあろう youtube 神戸てですのブームん
ハロー有数完璧でございます行けずんぶん
ハローこれは並行レンズが動い高の人が入ってくるとする
ていただいてそのあとにもう何かお話できたらを外しちゃってもいい
はいその本人がどう動くかを見たい取ってるわけねはいそれはね
そのぶんぶん youtube でみんなねあ部分幅 youtube で
分ほど youtube だったら近くまで来ると思うん
ここらへんに来たら目が悪くもあっても近くに来たらば
ブンブンハード youtube ba 着込む運輸や遺贈 z もの反応に合わせて
2人はもう中によっていただいてては行こう
結果も1本厳しくなりこの今なってくるかもそうそう
ペルビックしますいいねぇ
いいいいい
[音楽]
完全母が見えづらそう
私はずっと言うんじゃないですか
par
運動道
ハロー9あれある宇宙
な髪へさぁ
ポン
宇高ができます
ブルーストライプ
はいあーん
ai
や
通りください
じゃん水橋ん左ます
こんにちは l 2です
dare
ええええええ
えええええええ
どうぞ
もう一台ずつで者もちゃいましたもたらし外とれるん
何度させ
と youtube であったまってすって言ってもよろしくね
なんか嫌がってるんですよ
i 演奏するよねーちょっと注意てありますよねうん
エッグ何の減少さまッスイブの税務署におじいちゃんがいたらかーっ
あーそれそれだけだけど4つはちょっと距離が
たーっ by あ
部落民母は姉ひっ
海部郡を知っ
んん
youtube の方でしょアース不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不不不不不不ちゅーぶりっ
あーユーチューバーアーチーパティ物品ブーブー衣料品を吸ってるんですよそれもう
ちょいマシン
前半だ誰のネタって
尻尾まで勉強してないな駒があるんですかいいことってありますたとえが
生やしたいですねっ
えええええええええ
教えてもらっ
me
かマジメル分力チキンっ
どうぞあっぶー分払おう youtube
ています
[音楽]
ブーブー l
今日始めたと言う症状悪化となった
me
今日は何タイプ
1個
いやわかんないよ
pou dou dou
ほとんど動画を撮って取られるなんですかねぇ
日本なるああああから採用されるのはなくつかない編成
[音楽]
ブーバーし
コラージュこれはねこれは何か大丈夫
どんどんは尺ブンブンたっけ日本語んか部分が多くあった
べべんか
[音楽]
me
あっはっ